[Music]
I'd now like to introduce today's on the
shoulders of giants speaker so it's my
pleasure to introduce Barry bearish
professor Barry Barris is an
experimental physicist at Caltech who
has been closely involved in some of the
most important physics experiments of
modern history in 1994
professor barish became the principal
investigator for LIGO laser
interferometer gravitational-wave
Observatory that you'll be hearing more
about leading the ambitious project that
went on to observe gravitational waves
this past September professor bearish
became LIGO director in 1997 in the same
year founded the LIGO scientific
collaboration an international
collective of over a thousand scientists
who are dedicated to the study of
gravitational waves and recently
professor Barris has turned his efforts
to another ambitious project directing
the international linear collider global
design effort from 2006 to 2013 and with
that please join me in welcoming
professor Barry barish
[Applause]
I'm an experimental physicist and what
I'm gonna try to do today is try to show
you by one case example which is
basically gravity leading up to
gravitational waves and how science
works in physics as an interplay between
the experiment and theory how it makes
wrong turns we're maybe personalities
come in and so I'm going to trace the
history as a case example up to and
including gravitational waves with a
hint at what maybe comes next for us if
I get through all this so we're gonna
start with Newton but before we start
with Newton to make sure I get to it
basically this is the reason why several
of us are here which is a picture of a
computer a computer simulation of what
it what fits an observation that we made
last fall and reported last February of
two black holes going around each other
and merging into one object and that's
what we observed so what what is that
two black holes a black hole is when
there's been a gravitational collapse of
something of a large star for example
giving such intense gravity that nothing
can get back out so the simplest
explanation of a black hole is that's
what it is the most important thing to
realize is that it's incredibly small
the size of each of these black holes is
about the size of metropolitan New York
but it weighs 30 times the mass of our
Sun so that's why the gravity is so far
is incredibly strong two of them are
going around each other much like the
earth around the Sun only they're equal
and mass pretty much and slowly they're
losing energy and merged into each other
as you saw in that in that picture while
they're doing that in order to merge
into each other they're losing energy
and that that energy it comes out in the
form of gravitational waves which 1.3
billion years later we've detected so
this thing happened 1.3 billion years
ago we got our technology good enough to
act
see it when it came through the earth
last September so I'm gonna come back to
that we're gonna lead up to him I'm
gonna start with Newton since this this
talk is even labeled after a famous
saying of Newton's and where he started
with gravity how it led to Einsteins
gravity and then to us both
experimentally and theoretically so I
think we all know Newton's theory of
gravity is probably one of the most
successful theories in science it lasted
more than 200 years and explained the
awful lot he really recognized as you
kind of see in this picture what happens
when you have two massive objects
separated from each other he he somehow
put together a connection before we knew
it that when the Apple falls from the
tree and the moon goes around the earth
that they're they're governed by the
same theoretical reason gravity and so
that's the word universal gravity that
he developed and he made a formula which
you'd all seen in school that is that
the force between two massive objects is
a product of those two masses it's
inversely proportional to the square the
distance you separate them and this
governed by some constant G which I'll
talk about in a minute he did more he
actually in doing this he did the
calculus and proved that you could take
the distance between these two and just
take them as if all the mass was at the
center of each one so it's not some
complicated thing that you have to look
where you talk to each mass is but you
can take the center he proved that if
you had an inverse square law like this
that it would lead to elliptical orbits
around the Sun which was a thing that
then if it's going to be the planets or
the moon you have to have and that all
led to something that he then published
eventually in the Principia that's the
clean picture just like when you read
our paper the picture you get is that a
hundred years ago
Einstein predicted gravitational waves a
hundred years later we detected them the
actual story has more complexity than
that and even this one does it turns out
that that's what we know about Newton
but the problem is actually more
complicated there was another very good
scientist at that time the
in Britain at the Royal Society named
Robert Hooke and he was a physicist and
we know him mostly for kind of his
freshman physics law which is shown on
the right that is if you have a spring
and you put a weight on it and stretch
it it'll stretch twice as far if you put
twice as much weight on there or twice
as much force on it but he also was a
very broad scientist he got very
enamored with the microscope and he
studied a lot of geological things rocks
and things but he got interested also in
old fossils and he studied old fossils
and actually was one of the first people
that came up with the conclusion that
there was biological evolution
so Hooke was actually a pretty sound
scientist however he ran into Newton he
claimed at one point this is before the
Principia was published that he invented
the inverse square law and that he had
written a letter to Newton which
nobody's ever seen and it became a
dispute between them Newton when he
wrote the Principia then he said he
wouldn't publish the Principia because
of this dispute when he wrote it
finally and published it there's no
mention of Hooke anywhere in the
Principia which is kind of a shame but
that's the fact so it just starts with a
confusion which I'm going to try to
emanate the second thing that happened
is that we talked about this formula
here but we didn't talk about gee the
strength of the interaction that took a
hundred years to figure it out what G
was and I'll show you how that's done
but also there was no sense of what
caused this force this is an empirical
formula but no one conjectured what
caused the Apple default of the earth
there were all kinds of ideas that you
read about for example planets around
the Sun which are about wrong that the
Sun had some sort of magnetic field that
basically did it which isn't the reason
so basically this is an empirical
formula and the next problem was to
determine the strength of this and
whether it was Universal and that was
done a hundred years later by a
Cavendish and he did in a very clever
experiment he built what we call
torsion balance and that's a long wire
and on the end of the wires is a rod and
he put two lead weights on the end of
the rod and then he did all the careful
work of twisting it letting it go how
much he had to strain it to twist it to
calibrate it all and then he brought up
to heavy weight heavy lead weights next
to it and measured how far it moved and
when he did that he then could determine
the strength in the laboratory of this
constant gene and he got an answer which
I have here six point seven five ten to
the minus eleven and the units that we
use interestingly he was almost exactly
right you can see I put just for
reference what the number is now and so
this is impressive and that was kind of
the experiment coming into it the next
thing that happened is celestial
mechanics and this is kind of an
interesting story about how science
proceeds first of all this theory was
incredibly successful it a vine of
Newtons it explained everything from the
orbits of the planets which I talked
about already to the tides or even the
escape velocity from the earth so
everything you do with gravity on a
macroscopic sail scale and in two
hundred years or so that was only one
place where it didn't work and that was
the orbit of our smallest planet or a
planet closest to the Sun mercury which
has a orbit around the Sun about every
88 days and as it gets near the Sun it
gets perturbed by the presence of all
the other planets that are around and if
you calculate if you calculated it using
Newton's formula you didn't quite get
the right answer so the answer that was
gotten was 500 and can't read this 532
arc seconds per century from Newton's
theory and the actual measurements which
were good we're 575 so there's a small
discrepancy that existed and for some
people maybe that is at least part of
the motivation are part of the success
of Einstein's theory which came along
later
that's not quite true either there's
another guy named Ferrier who was a
mathematician
and did celestial mechanics and he
basically made celestial mechanics a
success as a field and respected by
doing the following thing he basically
used the formulas of Kepler and Newton
he calculated the orbit of Uranus and
found that there were discrepancies in
that orbit from those those theories
those formulas and he predicted then
that it was because there was a missing
planet Neptune which is the name that he
gave it that it was missing and he
predicted them where it would be because
otherwise it wouldn't fix the problem so
he predicted where it would be the story
goes that then he sent a letter to a
astronomer in in Germany in Berlin and
it took five days for the letter to get
there he took him to account those five
days he knew how long it would take the
astronomer got the letter this is the
story at least the astronomer got the
letter he then looked up at the sky and
the place that that was predicted by
Ferrier and within one degree he found
Neptune and at least the part of the
story is true is that he predicted
Neptune I don't know with all the colors
true but this made celestial mechanics a
let's say a viable subject he went on
he's the guy that saw that mercury had
an orbit that wasn't quite right so he
tried the same idea on Mercury so
whether the Newton's theory is right or
not he said okay it's gonna be just like
Neptune and Uranus and there's something
missing he called that Vulcan and he
said it will either be a small planet or
maybe a series of small objects that
were between mercury and the Sun he
predicted what they were he gave him the
name and they've never been found
they've been looked for even by NASA in
recent years but they've never been seen
of course they were reinvented for Star
Trek so those of you
so that we know so that's the that's
basically where the situation was when
Einstein came along there was not a
great case that Newton's theory didn't
work
in fact this in fact they didn't find
Vulcan but maybe they were experiments
weren't good enough at that point so
some people think that that was the
motivation
Einstein had developed the theory of
special relativity in 1905 and he
extended it to include accelerations
which is eventually gravity and ten
years after his three papers that most
of us in physics idolized kind of in
1905 he came out with the theory of his
theory of gravity and that theory of
gravity forget the formula in detail
that theory of gravity basically had the
feature that it unified all of space in
space-time one one universal or one word
space-time of course my laptop doesn't
understand that are mr. gates because it
puts little waves under space-time when
I typed it in so oh you still have to
teach him that space-time as a word
anyway Einstein came up with this theory
and in addition if he had the right
answer for Mercury but that's not an
enormous triumph obviously yeah but it
was a good start that guy gave the right
answer for Mercury around the Sun and
when we come out with a new theory of
nature one of its ingredients of course
is to explain things that haven't been
explained before but that can maybe be
done non uniquely you can make many
theories that will explain something
that you didn't know before in this case
the theory was good enough to predict
some new things and the thing that it
predicted that's most famous was the
bending of light or the calculation of
exactly how much light would Bend if it
went near a massive object Einstein's
theory has a not as the as the thing
that causes gravity is a curvature
space-time and so if you get near a
massive object it doesn't matter whether
you have something of mass going by or
something that's not mad
like photons going by they're gonna
follow the path of the distortions of
space-time and curve as they go by so he
calculated the curvature that it would
have by the way it also curves in
Newton's theory but not as much he he
calculated the curvature that it would
have and that was followed up by Arthur
Eddington who in 1919 went to the
southern hemisphere and an expedition
and looked at the bending of light
through an eclipse of the Sun where you
could see galaxies moved behind and he
got the right answer are basically he
got the same answer as Newton as
Einstein had predicted this was a great
triumph it's the thing it is the single
thing that they dine Stein famous
worldwide that hit newspapers all over
the world and basically not his
wonderful articles in 1905 but the
bending of light was what captured the
public in in about 1920 I've looked at
that data from Eddington which other
people probably have now and let's say
the requirements of what would be
convincing to the scientific community
were a lot different than when we did
LIGO our big issue in seeing
gravitational waves was to produce what
seems to be the standard you have to do
which is what's called five signal
that's that it's so in significantly
probable that it happened by some
statistical fluctuation that you can
ignore that it has to be that you did
something wrong in the case of in the
case of Eddington this was nowhere near
five Sigma by any stretch of the
imagination it but it was right and it
was repeated a couple years later and of
course that is history so it was right
that same feature of the bending of
light can actually be seen if you go to
the southern hemisphere and some of you
probably have seen it and that's called
the Einstein cross and it's quasar image
that appears around us by central
glow from a nearby galaxy and it's
visible and looking like this cross and
that feature so you can see with your
naked eyes but for astronomers this idea
that you basically can have a curvature
around objects means you can look at
objects that are dark and see the
curvature around them and it's become
kind of a cottage industry for for
astronomers what's called gravitational
lensing so that basically came out of
this whole thing I don't know if that
convinces you that Einstein's theory has
anything to do with with the real world
but this one will and that is all of you
maybe not as much in New York as we do
in Los Angeles but you drive around your
car using GPS and GPS relies on general
relativity I'll explain that to you
uh-huh
maybe I use a picture of somebody
walking just because it's New York so if
you wanted to walk and guide yourself
around then you have this picture so
what is this the reason why general
relativity matters for GPS and is a good
illustration that GPS really Ben Stein
theory of general relativity is relevant
to all of us first these satellites are
going fast they're going 24,000 miles an
hour and we have a something we learn as
soon as we learn special relativity and
that is moving clocks move more slowly
so that's true we applied special
relativity which is something that's
well established and if we do that we
find that we have to make a correction
I'll tell you how big the correction is
but how much it matters in a minute a
correction of minus seven microseconds
per day so just because of special
relativity the fact that they're going
fast the actual clocks are going to go
slower and we have to correct for it
somehow of course you can put something
right in the satellites to do that but
that's not the whole answer there's
actually a bigger correction that comes
from general relativity and that's the
fact that the satellites are have about
a quarter of the gravitational field
that we have here on the surface of the
earth because they're way out and
because they have less gravitational
feel they have less space time orbit
around them and in that case clocks move
faster and in fact if you calculate it
with general relativity they gained 45
microseconds a day so the total is the
difference between those two where the
GPS correction is 38 microseconds a day
does that matter yes the accuracy that
you need to put us on the road is about
30 nanoseconds in order to be 10 meter
resolution to be on a road you have to
have something like 30 nanosecond
resolution which is a thousand times
better than the 30 microseconds a day or
if you divide by the number of minutes
in a day every minute or so you're going
to wander off the road if you don't make
the correction so now we need that
correction and so you should believe
that general relativity matters and
actually works this is a regime of
general relativity that's less
interesting for us as physicists it's
what we call the weak field limit and
there it works it works in other ways
but this is kind of the most dramatic I
think for those of us that walk around
the streets or drive our cars we're
interested in what I'll get to later in
Lego as creating a laboratory where we
can study general relativity where the
theory is most interesting and most in
question and that is when the fields are
incredibly strong like in these black
holes and that's why studying black
holes become so interesting to us in
terms of testing and understanding
general relativity okay so Einstein then
had put this theory out of general
relativity and a year later he predicted
gravitational waves he did this not
rigorously but in analogy in a sense to
electrodynamics where we have
electromagnetic waves and the similarity
in the equations and so he predicted
gravitational waves in exactly 100 years
ago or in the winter of 1916 and he
wrote a paper and that paper was badly
flawed but it's the paper we refer to
when we say that a hundred years ago
Einstein predicted gravitational waves
that paper has a series of errors in it
but one of them is a even a factor of
two and the magnitude of the
gravitational waves the idea that there
were gravitational waves was right
you wrote a follow-up paper two years
later in 1918 and in that paper he fixed
the errors fixed the error made it a
factor of two it's still not a rigorous
derivation of gravitational waves but it
has an important element it basically
defines the source so the source of
gravitational waves he shows in that
paper is is from a quadrupole moment or
a quadrupole formula and to remind you
when we have electromagnetic waves which
we compared with electromagnetic waves
comes from what we call a dipole moment
if you have a plus charge and a minus
charge and you wiggle them to each other
they emit electromagnetic waves
depending on how fast we do it we have
microwaves or infrared or ultraviolet or
whatever are radio waves same thing here
we have a quadrupole moment and said
that's for instead of a dipole moment in
order to make gravitational waves and so
we know how to produce them if we wanted
to and and again how fast you do it will
depend on what the frequency is of those
waves just like electromagnetic waves
they're basically produced I'll come to
in a second they're produced I want to
bring one one other point in first the
gravitational waves he also shows travel
with the speed of light so the
fundamental difference that we that
matters kind of conceptually between
Newton and Einstein is that Newton's
theory when the Apple Falls is that you
have what we call instantaneous action
at a distance so wherever we are when it
happens we detected immediately there's
nothing in between well in Einstein's
theory we produce a messenger if its
gravitational waves that travels at the
same speed as he has in the problem
which we call the speed of light but
it's basically the speed in the problem
and basically then it takes in our case
for the example I showed in the
beginning 1.3 billion you
for the signal because it was distant to
get to us that we're gonna show in a
little bit and so Einstein has the
propagation the propagation is not
however like the propagation of light
waves which is particles it's actual
distortion of space and time okay the
story doesn't end there as I said the
stories become quite contorted Einstein
moved to the US and in 1933 from Germany
wrote two famous papers Einstein
Podolsky and Rosen which was a famous
paper about quantum mechanics and a
second one about with Einstein and Rosen
that had to do with what we call
wormholes now he didn't call it that and
then he wrote a third paper in 1936 with
Rosen that third paper was entitled do
gravitational waves exist you might
guess from the title that he had
conclude at almost twenty years later
that they don't exist after he had
proposed them earlier and he submitted
this paper to Physical Review this is
the man that received the paper John
Tate was the editor of Physical Review
at that time physical reviews our main
journal as certainly at that time John
Tate then took the paper and he sent it
for peer review and we know now from the
records at physical review that he sent
it to this guy Howard Percy Robertson
Howard person Robertson was also a
general relativist he was on sabbatical
from Princeton and was at Caltech my
institution on sabbatical when he got
the the paper to review and you can see
on the second line as einstein-rosen and
the dates they came and he sent it back
he actually found the mistake in the
paper I had to do with coordinate system
the fact that Einstein used a single
coordinate system to cover all of
space-time which is very difficult and
found singularities that he thought
basically were false and were the reason
that they were assuming there were
gravitational waves but there weren't
and Robertson reform
in a different coordinate system a
cylindrical coordinate system and showed
that the singularity went away did his
review sent it to mr. Tate who was the
editor of his Rev and mr. Tate then sent
a letter which I've seen but I'm not
duplicating here back to Einstein that
was very mild he basically said the part
I took in quotes that he would be glad
to have Einstein's reaction to the
referees comments and criticism nothing
about whether he published it or not
Einstein's response was this and he
actually wrote a written response and
that written response which he wrote in
German but it's translated was dear sir
we mr. Rosen who had gone back to the
Soviet Union by this time and I had sent
you our manuscript for publication but
had not authorized you to show it to
specialists before it's printed I see no
reason to address the in any case
erroneous comments of your anonymous
expert on the basis of this incident I
prefer to publish the paper elsewhere
respectfully Einstein there's a PS
saying that Rosen agrees with it even
though he's gone back to the Soviet
Union so he went on just as he said here
and he sent it to a more obscure journal
it was actually the journal for the
Franklin Institute in in Pennsylvania in
those days we didn't have kind of a
high-tech way that we published now and
the publication's had to be set up and
printed and read and that took months
and so this was percolating through the
system at the Franklin Institute they
accepted the article as was written
which was exactly like the one sent to
Physical Review in the meantime Rosen
had gone back to the Soviet Union and
Einstein had a new assistant who was a
early important cosmologists Leopold
infill and Infeld then was important in
the final resolution so the sabbatical
of Robertson although these are
anonymous reviewers so nobody knows that
it what happens
to the reviews that are done return to
Princeton and when he returned to
Princeton he had no idea what had
happened in this but he happened to be
friend mister in film so in after he met
in filled they in talking physics Infeld
he mentioned to Infeld that he didn't
believe this conclusion and Infeld
showed him the proof that he had of
Einstein's and Rosen's idea and
Robertson Robertson continued to then
basically show him where the error was
so in Phil went back and discussed this
with Einstein and Einstein responded
saying he'd already found the error in
the meantime the article came back from
the Franklin Institute got rewritten it
changed the title changed the substance
and basically if you read the first
sentence it says basically that he had
rigorous solutions of the cylindrical
gravitational wave and the present
semanas paper so it became a paper that
carried the the proof of gravitational
waves further
so he wasn't embarrassed by this he's
never officially come out against
gravitational waves however Einstein
never published anything again are in
gravitational waves and he never
published anything again in Physical
Review to be fair peer review is a
system that was invented not long before
that it's probably true he had moved to
the US in 1933 that he had never
experienced peer review so in his
articles published in Germany he
probably never had peer review his two
famous papers that I mentioned as far as
we can tell both were accepted by the
editor at that point who had that he
could send these out to peer review on
discretion at that point and so the two
articles the one with Podolsky and Rosen
and the one on wormholes that he
published weren't reviewed so this is
probably the first review that he ever
experienced so there's his side of the
story as well but anyway
all's well that ends well the next thing
is as an experimentalist we like to
control all the variables so if we do a
measurement that's hard or easy or
whatever we do you really want to have
everything in your control so that you
can understand all the aspects so the
source the ends and in our case the
analogy here is to go back to Hertz in
the 1880s who demonstrated for the first
time electromagnetic waves and he did
this in a laboratory by starting with a
source of making electromagnetic waves
going far enough away so that you could
see the wave nature and prove there were
electromagnetic waves and this is a
famous experiment if you wanted to do
this in the laboratory for gravitational
waves what would it take to do that and
why don't we do that so let me just give
you a an imaginary experiment so just
like these two objects that go around
each other that we're going to talk
about later black holes we could sit in
our laboratory and make something
similar by making a big barbell and
putting a lot of weight on each end and
rotating it just like that and it's
going to emit gravitational radiation so
I've put in numbers here just to give
you a feeling of what that will take you
can ignore the little formula it just
tell us what the strength of the whole
effect is and so I've put kind of
unreasonable but trying to make the the
numbers larger unreasonable numbers in
if we took masses of a thousand
kilograms for the two masses separated
them by a metre
spun at a thousand times a second get
out of the lab because it's pretty
dangerous and go away about three
hundred meters you actually want to go
much further than that to see the wave
nature but I've tried to make the effect
as big as we can then so we spin it then
the effect is and just remember the
number 10 to the minus 35 so this is the
fractional change that's created by a
gravitational wave the numbers that I'm
going to show you from the object that
we that we've detected are more like 10
to the minus 21 14 orders of magnitude
that's 0 0 14 times larger than this and
we can barely detect it as you can see I
spent years developing the
to do this so we're nowhere near the
ability to do what an experimental
Mentalist once which is to carry the
whole problem from start to finish
inside our laboratory so instead we're
forced to look out in the universe of
course that in this case turns out to be
very fortunate because what we see out
in the universe turns out to be so
interesting in its own right so we don't
don't just a measure gravitational wave
so here's the same numbers just for
completeness for the object that we saw
that I'm going to talk about that gives
something like 10 to the minus 21 again
their weight their mass is the roughly
30 times the mass of the Sun there's
their radius is 100 kilometer 100
kilometers and the frequency where we
detected is roughly a hundred Hertz and
if we do that then and the distance away
we wish we've measured if we do that we
get a strength of something like 10 to
the minus 21 about 14 orders of
magnitude stronger than this barbell has
just been so that's why we go out into
space okay so we're looking then driven
this way for Astrophysical sources they
can give us signals in the detectors
that we're I'll talk about now a little
bit that we bill so what is the effect
the effect is that if a gravitational
wave comes it distorts space-time in a
way shown in this picture at the
frequency that it's coming through you
or me or our detectors it'll make in one
direction stretch and there at the same
time a squash in the other direction and
then go back and forth at the frequency
of the gravitational wave so in this
case it's once a second or so but and we
try to measure that this is just on the
on that on this side just the picture of
that statically but it basically goes
back and forth and that our problem then
is to make an instrument if we want to
detect these that can measure this
difference in the two directions
fortunately it's one of the best kinds
of instruments we have what's called an
interferometer so we want to measure
this with interferometer from the
metrics techniques but that's not where
the problem
so the problem of doing it
experimentally began with a man named
Joe Weber it began in the 1960s and he
had the idea that you could take a very
sensitive way to measure it would be to
take a great big bar of aluminum in this
case instrumented so that any changes in
its shape could be detected easily and
it could be detected even if they're
very very small and if a gravitational
wave came through it would distort the
distorted and we know that the amount of
distortion or what happens in a big
object like this is it has a resonant
frequency if you hit it it rings at some
frequency so the advantage and good
thing is that it has a lot of
sensitivity near its resonance frequency
the bad thing is it doesn't have very
much width if you get off the resident
frequency you can't see anything very
much I won't have any sensitivity and
the instrument that we're going to talk
about in a while though interferometer
we have a broadband ability to see so
that's an improvement but the concept
was is and he pursued this he was at the
University of Maryland he had been at
Princeton before and had come up with
the idea
he never detected gravitational waves
I'll show you that but we have a long
legacy of what he's done other than in
addition to basically beginning the
field experimentally so Joe Weber really
was the pioneer that began the
experimental efforts to see
gravitational waves but if we look at
LIGO which I'm going to come to in a
while we've actually benefited from some
of the techniques that he invented I
have three listed here the sensitivity
calculation and noise analysis that he
did is similar to what we do that is
understand what it is that gives you
signals besides the thing you're looking
for that he did a coincidence for
background rejection just what we do we
have two detectors one in Louisiana one
in Washington and we asked that they be
coincident within the time resolution of
the gravitational waves and lastly he
even explored how to measure what the
backgrounds were by looking at things
that had the same time
and things that don't have the same
timing all three of those are basically
legacies that we've inherited and use as
part of the basic scheme for detecting
gravitational waves even though the
technique is quite different the
sensitivity of the bars as I said is
limited by their narrow width and that
practical size that you can make it I
showed you it's a fractional change in
in stretching or squashing and so the
bigger you make it the better and you
can only make a bar so big this effort
though to do bars went for a long ways
because clever people decided you can
make it better by making by cooling it
and until we got LIGO working in the
early part of this century these bars
were running as as one of the main
search elements to look for
gravitational waves now they're in the
in the storehouse there's another thing
that came from him and that is his
student Robert forward was one of the
first people in the u.s. to actually
look at the idea of using
interferometers he worked with Webber
and then he went to Hughes research labs
in California and actually built a
little interferometer so he had that
history this idea was then picked up by
my colleague Ray Weiss who developed the
the real ability to what it would take
to make a real interferometer that would
be sensitive enough a few years later so
Webber though unfortunately as great as
he was in bringing all this was a much
better technologist and visionary than
he was as a scientist in 1969 he
published and even though in Steiner
couldn't he published in Physical Review
the discovery of gravitational waves and
this is the figure from that paper so
the first this is his first discovery
and that's what he said is he saw a blip
one at argon lab near Chicago and one at
University of Maryland this proved to be
wrong and unfortunately this happened
more than once in his career so he
somewhat spoiled his reputation by
having wrong science results which is
devastating as a scientist despite the
fact that he made such an incredible
impact on the field
we have another way that gravitational
waves have been observed and that is
indirectly so if you look at the picture
here we have two objects these are
called neutron stars one going around
the other and again in this elliptical
orbit they're going to radiate some
gravitational radiation this was Taylor
and Hulse and they were studying this
fast rotating one on the Left here which
was rotating at 17 times a second notice
that it had a modulation of about once
every eight hours and that was due to
the fact that there were a pair once
they just got decided just once they
discovered there was a pair then in
subsequent years it was the period of
the long-lived one the long period the
eight hour period are almost eight hour
period was measured over a period of
time and as it radiates radiates
gravitational radiation that period gets
a little faster and a little faster and
in a million years or so we would detect
it in LIGO but at this point the data
that they had is published is shown on
the picture on the on the right and in
that picture you see a bunch of dots and
the vertical scale it's years I'm sorry
in the vertical scale its seconds and
that's how many seconds faster or
shorter the period got and on the bottom
scale is years so over about 20 years
the actual period of this almost eight
hour period got shorter by about 20
seconds and they measured that very
accurately as you can see by all those
little dots the line that's shown on top
of the dots is the line that's
calculated from general relativity so
knowing all the features of that system
which they had measured independently
you can calculate the line it's not a
fit to the impressive thing about this
to me is it's not a fit to the data it's
a line drawn from the parameters that
they have which is unbelievingly
impressive that you can actually
calculate independently and it falls
right on the line so this is a very
strong indication that gravitational
waves
and caused this effect if we wanted to
measure this system this way we'd wait
about a million years and it would be in
our frequency Bend okay so now the
direct detection and I'm going to do
this in a kind of qualitative way we
have the same problem what we want to do
is see the squashing and stretching of
free masses as they move through time so
I've drawn here the technique that we
have superpose on a circle of free
masses imagine masses that are free to
move as they're there so a an
interferometer measures basically the
time it takes for light to go down the
arms Paris on ttle and the light going
vertical we basically send the light and
both split the light from a laser send
it in both directions bring it back and
if it comes back at the same time we can
already n things so they cancel each
other but if one arm gets a little
longer than the other because of
gravitational wave came through then
they won't pencil at that time and we
measure that in time evolution the
details of how that's really done which
is very important and very clever and
very difficult were explained by Ray
Weiss my colleague yesterday in a
lecture and you just have to go on to
the website here and I don't whenever
they put it up and see how the
interferometry really works to do this I
don't have time to do that today but it
stretches and squashes like this so
that's basically what we're doing is
changing the length of the arms and then
measuring the signal that we get we have
to have free masses for two reasons one
is we want free masses like the picture
conceptually but we also want to isolate
the masses from the earth itself and we
do that by hanging the masses from wires
and it's a pendulum basically and it
wants to move and shake itself move
itself and has a natural frequency but
that frequency is lower than the
frequency band we work in so we're able
to have them hang from a wire use all
kinds of isolation and make them as
isolated from the ground as possible let
me just show you in a little video that
I didn't make this idea just to
emphasize that light comes from from a
source which is a
goes through a mirror gets split goes
out the two arms comes back almost
cancels but if any light goes to the
receivers then we see that light this is
just showing the same idea with waves
themselves because the light comes in
different waves and how they come back
and they cancel are nearly canceled
and then what we see in the detector so
that's the basic idea and I said it as a
as a more quantitative explanation just
go to race talk when it gets posted and
he does it in nice detail okay so how
small is this change that we want to
measure that's the technique and you can
learn more about the technique from Ray
but how small is that we ultimately want
to go to something like ten to the minus
nineteen meters we talk about 10 to the
minus 18 but it's 10 to the minus 19 is
kind of our goal
and so how small is that let me remind
you how small it is a meter we all know
how big a meter is it's basically that
long the human hair some of us have some
left is about a hundred microns in width
so that's ten thousand times smaller
than a meter okay we can all handle that
the wavelength of light like the light
in the laser beam is a hundred times
smaller than that that's basically a
mite one micron the atomic diameter now
getting two things are a little harder
for us to visualize but the atomic
diameter is ten thousand times smaller
than that and that's ten to the minus
ten meters the proton getting into
something that's basic and using
particle accelerators for example it's a
size of 10 to the minus 15 meters that's
a hundred thousand times smaller than
the atom and we want to go a factor of
ten thousand smaller than that so that's
the magic and maybe the reason people
thought this would never work but it
does so that's the goal and you have to
do a lot better than the simple picture
I did drew of the interferometer to make
it that good
so we built these instruments they're
large for the reason that I said the
amount of effect depends on how big you
make it so the largest practical size
the time we
built this was to make the arms the two
arms on the interferometer about four
kilometers long so they're four
kilometers long this picture is LIGO in
Livingston Louisiana and you'll notice
the terrain it's all it's a commercial
forest and along the way we build it is
to build up build it up on a berm to get
it high enough above the surface so it
doesn't flood and so we build it to the
500-year floodplain that's about 15 feet
up and in Louisiana add another meter
for safety so we don't get flooded in
the lifetime with LIGO and in doing that
it makes we borrow the dirt from a
channel which immediately fills with
water and that's what you see on the
right side and then alligators fish and
everything else you can imagine so
that's a terrain we live with in
Louisiana there's no bedrock so trying
to make a stable physical structure is
very difficult it's basically floating
on water
the second LIGO Observatory which is
identical for our purpose is totally
different from the standpoint of this
picture and reality it's on high desert
it's in Hanford Washington so it's
basically on sand or it's you have to go
very very deep to find any water and yet
the two instruments we make and their
sensitivity are basically identical how
we try to keep them identical so that's
the two instruments we have to in order
for confidence like it was done like
Webber was trying to do but also to tell
where this gravitational wave when we
detect it comes from so once in Hanford
Washington once in Livingston Louisiana
there are 3,000 kilometers apart at the
speed of light if we have a signal or
gravitational wave that first goes
through living Sun and then goes to
Hanford and goes at the speed of light
which is a speed of gravitational waves
it'll take ten milliseconds to go from
one to the other if we go the other
direction it'll take ten milliseconds to
go from Hanford to Livingston and if we
happen to have a gravitational source
that was directly overhead between the
two they would come at exactly the same
time so that's the scheme
we ask that they both happen and we tell
something about the direction by the
difference in the to the event that well
I'll talk about or show you it was six
point nine milliseconds different coming
first in Livingston and then to Hanford
Washington and I'll talk about what we
use that for in a minute this is just
some more of the internal workings of of
LIGO it has a great big vacuum pipe yet
I think it's the largest high vacuum
system in the world it's 1.2 meter
diameter pipes a total of 16 kilometres
of vacuum in the two sites and these are
the kind of working parts of like Oh big
chambers where we put the optics and and
mirrors to guide the laser beam and
these have a lot of ports and things
because we have a lot of test equipment
and side beams and all kinds of things
that we do which I'm not going to talk
about today so what limits us so we can
make it big enough we can calculate that
we're going to try to do as well as I
said but in reality we get limited by
things that get in our way and these are
the most common ones first if the vacuum
isn't good enough and that's why we make
very high vacuum we get residual
scattering off the vacuum itself so the
light goes down scatters off the vacuum
you can imagine a lot of ways you can
get in trouble with that you can have
particles that scatter then off-the-wall
photons and back have a different path
length and are out of time and so forth
so we need to keep the scattering down
as much as we can
second as much as we think of a laser
beam has very very stable it's not
stable enough for us so we do a
tremendous amount of work to stabilize
the laser in its wavelength and in its
amplitude that's the second thing we
have to do to keep from being able to do
this the third is that we have to
isolate ourselves well enough from the
ground this is a huge problem we
basically are living on the earth where
the ground shakes a lot and we do that
in two ways as I'll show you the next
one is that we were at room temperature
and at room temperature
protons and molecules move around in any
substance so the mirrors that we have
are made out of molecules and they move
around something we call Brownian motion
and lastly there's more subtle things
that we like to increase the light level
as high as we can to get the best
measurements but if we do that we have
other problems that come in in this case
what I've shown here is something we
call quantum noise and that is as we
increase the light level I'm making more
more powerful lasers we produce a
pressure on the test masses themselves
that we have to worry about if we put
that all together we get a curve that
looks like this now what's a look at and
this is the shaded area this is an old
picture so it's not the advanced LIGO
but it shows the concept if we look in
the shaded region that's the highest
level that we're limited by something
all the lines below are the things that
we try to control and make sure they're
below and we're eventually limited by
three things at the lowest Center at the
lowest level on the left
very steep is seismic noise that's the
shaking of the earth at the highest and
we're limited by what's called shot
noise which is really fundamentally how
many photons you have so it's photon
statistics and in the middle we're
limited by this thermal noise the fact
that we're working at room temperature
it's a nasty problem for experimentalist
because we don't have one problem that
we have to deal with we have three
different ones
the total sensitivity region might look
familiar to you it's essentially the
same as the year so the audio but so we
talked about being in the audio band we
basically have ears that respond to tens
of Hertz and go up to thousands of Hertz
just like this does and it's really for
the same physical reasons we live on the
earth that's where the earth is quietest
and so our laboratory for LIGO is on the
earth and although we're not dealing
with audio things we have the same basic
things that limit us so we work in
what's called the audio band and and it
comes from the fact that that's the
laboratory that we have which is here on
earth so that's our sensitivity and it
looks like this curve here this is a
real curve now
lines that go up you can ignore those
are little resonances that we have in
our system and just ignore them for now
if you want to learn about them in more
detail we can talk the the colored the
colored lines are the data from our
earlier measurements that we were we
didn't detect gravitational waves and
then we went through a big rebuilding
program to improve in three directions
to improve the power of the laser to be
better at high frequencies I said it's
the number of photons or how fast you
can sample at the low frequencies to do
better seismic isolation and the middle
levels to make bigger and better test
masses and suspension systems to try to
control that that region we did those
improvements and completed them about I
don't know a year and a half or so ago
and technically these are just some
pictures I'll just show you quickly the
laser that we have only message to take
away here from here is this a lot more
complicated than the little one I would
use as a pointer if I didn't have glass
up here and it has all these stabilizing
elements in it the mirrors themselves
are fantastically wonderful objects
these are made out of few silica they're
a twenty centimeters thick 35
centimeters or 34 centimeters across
they're weigh 40 kilograms so they're
big things the optical surface is that
the best the best we can make and
they're coated so that they they
basically tell the eye they look
perfectly clear but they're coated so
that they reflect at the wavelength of
our laser which is 1024 nanometers this
is the suspension system as I say we
hang from wires we do it in a series of
four steps and this is done so that the
bottom layout level is as quiet as we
can make it we do all the controls and
higher levels and lastly and you can't
see this very well in the picture we
have a very complicated system of trying
to isolate ourselves from the ground
both passively by using basically very
advanced shock absorbers like you have
in your car but more recently by doing
it with
feedback system that does it does it
actively that is by measuring the motion
just like sound things that you were
using your ears on an airplane drowned
out the sound in the background we
correct for the motion now combination
of those has given us the improvements
that we needed to make this measurement
so the curves that I showed before were
the top curve here and we started
improving too with the physical
improvements we made on our way to get
to this very bottom line and we stopped
in between because of the fact that as
we increase the sensitivity say a factor
of two that's means that we look out
into the universe a factor of two
further and the number of galaxies stars
and so forth in the universe as we go
out a factor of two furthers our factor
of eight bigger because it goes as the
volume so having increased our our
sensitivity a factor of three at the
high frequencies and where we put in
active isolation at the low frequencies
it's even more we were able to make this
measurement so we turn the apparatus on
last September this is a familiar curve
that people have seen one is from LIGO
Livingston on the left the one on the
right is from Hanford Observatory and
what they show is there are seven
milliseconds apart what they show is
something that's getting bigger and
higher frequency and that's the motion
as it's going in it's going faster
around the around each other the two
objects and then they merge and they
merge at this merging and finally ring
down a little bit and that's the picture
which I'll show you what we calculate so
that drawn through there then in the
last is a line which comes from our best
fit using general relativity we now look
at that this is the picture that we have
going backwards now from what looks like
the data the top is the physical picture
of the different parts of the graph we
see that picture here that is basically
the picture that is extracted from the
raw data where the frequency gets
higher and higher the signal gets bigger
and bigger these are the two objects
getting closer and closer together these
very compact objects and then merging
and then there's a little bit of ring
down which we're not able to detect very
well at this point we fit all that with
general relativity and we're able to
tell the masses of the two objects were
able to tell the amount of energy that
was released into gravitational
radiation about three times the mass of
our Sun the equivalent of the mass of
our Sun radiated away and other things
about it how far away it is and so forth
if you look at the bottom picture here
to me it's very revealing of what's
happening first look at the the black
curve on the top and you see that the
separate it's the scale on the right
which is in units of what we call
Schwarzschild radii but that's about a
hundred kilometers each they start in
our band about 400 kilometers apart and
when they're finally merging they're
only about a hundred kilometers which is
their size and that's what you saw and
this all happens in about a quarter of a
second or less the other curve going up
is one that's astounding these things
although it didn't look like that in the
first movie that I showed you are highly
relativistic they're going at the
beginning at 30% the speed of light and
by the end when they're merging they're
up to about 60% of the speed of light so
it's a tremendously energetic system and
fast system we compare the times when it
arrived I kept saying they're seven
milliseconds apart if you remember how
you tell where something is from using
triangulation on a boat or something
this should tell us a ring in the sky
basically and if we had a third detector
which we will have soon in Italy then
you can do better you can tell two
points in two positions in the sky what
I show here is how well we actually are
able to tell the detection we can tell
it comes from the southern hemisphere
and it's this banana shaped thing that's
for us not very good it's about 500
square degrees but it's not the whole
ring and the reefs
it isn't the whole ring is that the true
detectors don't have spherical
acceptance they have an acceptance that
depends whether you're overhead or
inside and so forth and they're
separated from each other about 16
degrees on the Earth's surface and so
looking at how big the signal is in
Livingston compared to Hanford we're
actually able to rule out that pretty
much rule out the Northern Hemisphere
and so this is what we end up with it's
very important to us to be get this
localization much better because we're
now able to for the first time look at
this guy with gravitational waves and
you'd like to see that whatever you see
is it also seen in some sort of
electromagnetic radiation whether it's
visible or infrared or some other object
and of course this huge swath is not
good enough so the way we're going to do
that is to add other detectors there's
one that's been built and will soon be
hopefully in Italy French Italian
collaboration near Pisa and it should be
operational hopefully by the end of this
year and that will give us much better
resolution which I'm not going to show
you but much better and finally we've
been approved by the Indian government
to put a third interferometer we we are
contributing the interferometer and them
the infrastructure in India and that
should be finished in about five years
so that will in the end end give us much
better position we've just opened and
that's why this is so important and
exciting a totally different way of
looking at the sky we know there's a lot
of what we don't know is probably the
most important that there's things that
give gravitational signals that we don't
see electromagnetically in fact this
very first signal that we see this 30
solar mass black holes weren't known to
be there by any electromagnetic
experiments that have been done so
that's already new the known sources
that we expect to see I've just listed
here as the possible targets that we're
going to be looking looking for in the
next few years
on the upper right I show bursts that's
like the collapse of a star supernova or
a gamma
burst all these things that are seen
optically but the information that we
can get if we add information
gravitationally and give us great
insight for example into the collapse of
a star the collapse of a star is a
gravitational the physics is
gravitational the signal that's seen
optically is kind of a shock wave that
comes out and so to really understand it
the gravitational signals should be
added to the other so we hope to see the
collapse of a star gamma-ray sources
eventually as are in our sensitivity
improves what I call continuous sources
in the lower-right that's spinning
spinning objects that aren't totally
spherically symmetric examples are what
we call pulsars or neutron stars and if
they're young enough they're probably
not so so spherically symmetric and we
look for those as a continuous wave at
some frequency that they're rotating at
the lower left is a dream we're not able
to do that very well in the LIGO
bandwidth but that's to see signals from
the early universe lastly we're going to
improve the technologies in LIGO I
showed you we're only partway to where
we've designed to go we'll finish that
in the next few years we know how to go
beyond that and we'll keep improving we
gain as a cube with every improvement we
make but there's other improvements that
can go beyond that there's a detector
being made in Japan now that has two
improvements that will be important in
second or third generation detect in the
sense that like Oh advanced LIGO second
generation I would call this
two-and-a-half generations that is it
includes an advantage of being deep
underground
but in deep underground there's much
less seismic noise to worry about things
don't shake and they're making it an
attempt that we looked at but gave up on
in our time scale before and that is
cooling this system cooling the mirrors
so that we don't they don't have the
thermal noise that that we have there's
also been look both in the US but
primarily in Europe so far that how to
make a detector on the Earth's surface
that can go well beyond LIGO and in
Europe through a study they've done one
that would be deep underground ten
kilometers instead of
instead of four kilometers a triangle
which helps you do the polarization
which exists that I didn't talk about
that it's cryogenic and that it has two
Coptic o configurations one that will
work at very low frequencies and one
that would look at it work at much
higher frequencies we're looking at some
alternatives to this but the point is
that this we're not at the end of the
road at all we can develop this
technology over the coming years on the
Earth's surface to do much better than
we're doing now that's not the end of
the story we know how to do that but
just like in astronomy where the big one
of the big gains in the last decades has
been the ability to look at different
wavelengths looking at optical looking
at astronomical things that happened but
looking at them in the infrared and the
ultraviolet in the visible and different
wavelengths has been able to pull
together the dynamics similar to that
gravitational waves are going to be at
different frequencies we're working at
the very highest frequencies which means
we're working where things take
milliseconds to happen those are very
violent things that only take
milliseconds and we've seen one that's
this object coming together if we want
to look at and there's many
possibilities at things that take longer
timescales then if it's minutes or hours
we go in space you can't do that for the
reasons that I said on the earth we go
in space there's a program to go into
space it's called Lisa the Europeans are
supporting it it was supported by NASA
but because of budget problems that was
pulled back we're hoping that it'll be
put back into the NASA program possibly
stimulated some by our success but
that's a very important way to get to
longer timescales yet longer time scales
are done by pulsar timing on an array of
timing very accurately where the timing
gets affected by the passage of
gravitational waves and that can get to
years and decades and finally we can
look at the experiments that look at the
early universe signals billions of years
away
and look at the effect of what they
measure by the presence of gravitational
waves that affects the patterns that
they look at or the polarizations that
they see so the future in our mind is
really exciting and it'll take a long
time but opens up a totally new area of
physics and astronomy and with that I'll
close thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]